hello and welcome to my second video
this is Evan Pugh Schreck and I'm a
blogger
the reason I'm doing that one actually
is because I had an idea here's my
thinking I'm a nerdfighter and a writer
a nerd fighting writer a nerd writer
watch that's almost a W so I am getting
into the YouTube survey but first I
wanted to say congratulations to Maureen
Johnson in the name of the star it's
fantastic to get published graduation
whirring I'm going to find your book and
buy it well my Christmas was in a tree
house when I was 9 years old I was
playing truth or dare with a bunch of
people and someone there a girl named
Erica to kiss me and she did and I was
my first kiss and I couldn't fucking
believe it
casual clothing I don't know everything
I wear is pretty casual and I get most
good from the gap so probably 1699
really didn't know what I wanted to be
when I was a kid I was always told that
I would be an engineer like my dad I was
always good at science and math I never
liked them I liked history and
literature eventually I decided I wanted
to be a filmmaker by that time I was
already 17 years old does that count
really glad you asked about school
friends because these are the most
important people in my life I'm a writer
so I really could be anywhere in the
world but I choose to be in Los Angeles
because my friends are here that's the
reason it's the only thing in my life
that I've built that I think is worth
preserving friendship is certainly
something that you build over time it's
work I love these guys and girls and if
they were in Siberia that's right they
find a girl George if I'd a guy or Dias
though I always thought boosha boosha
would be a good name two-one-zero 500
Angeles Irvine exited he's my only
subscribers hope our I love you Cielo
thank you so much